hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to all
right
so everyone's asking me to do this
adventure time because of some sort of
adventure time Delos I don't know
well everyone's here telling me go ahead
and do it are they saying no no don't do
it because so much weird randomness will
just suddenly be incorporating your show
cuz that's what Adventure Time does well
I'm not afraid to shy away from
randomness that's wise
all right Jason it's business time come
on it's business day so business time I
just I like saying it that way so I will
say this the one thing I knew going into
this show that bad everyone it's a lot
of reasons that I guess were interested
you know in it at all is that just you
don't have to go to great detail but in
the very opening when he's getting stuff
out of the icebergs like a bike and a
computer and the businessmen and stuff
like that is that because of the
apocalypse
um yes okay good that's the one thing I
knew going in is that everyone has said
no no it's actually kind of about the
apocalypse and they kind of hint at it
that this is actually after the
apocalypse I don't know anything else
outside of that themselves I've had the
first hint of this there's something
that happened beforehand didn't that
this may actually be something familiar
yeah and in this episode you got you got
business man what has a kind of old
cellphone looks like out of the 80s
which I thought was kind of interesting
too I get me it's just how they draw
cell phones or or could type act or
something I don't know but they find
these businessmen and it's the angle I
thought they were gonna go is that they
they're obsessed with business they're
obsessed with work at least yeah and
they just want to work as hard as they
can on something and what were they
building like this gauntlet or there's
gonna lift up you have a gauntlet dock
and the Jake doesn't want bill this way
as the businessmen build and they put
together and then things get out of hand
what I thought they were gonna do is
when they say can you build this
gauntlet dock they go hmm I thought they
weren't gonna do any work but they were
going to advertise and through business
models of stuff like thank you other
people want to do the work and then they
would become like all the people working
what I think that first thing gets great
does they be getting paid but then they
in a world that doesn't really seem to
have money it looks like and then maybe
they would get like really bored by it
or they start to realize they don't like
the money but because the businessmen
are always on top I thought that was the
angle there
go for it but again I'm kind of like
that they did a different angle which is
they just love to work which is what I
felt really sad when there's sent away
at the end and I get it they're like you
know they're going out of control and
they're being really crazy and taking it
too far but at the same time like I
didn't feel a deserve for them to be put
back in a nice way they're thinking more
business than with emotion but it's like
they don't know any better they still
want you know like the one that gets
promoted it's like Oh what are we hoping
or two and say it's like they get they
just want to do well but at the same
time Ben tells them to put themselves in
the iceberg and they do it so it's like
they have an option oh yeah you know
they do it to themselves they do feel
kind of bad because they weren't like
bad guys person you know they were just
sort of very naive and all they knew was
their job and when they come out all
they still know is a job - they measure
themselves clearly only by their job
yeah which i think is very interesting
so I guess in a sense that's more
interesting so it's not that it's
necessarily business it's just their job
yeah and they don't care what their job
is they just want a job that they can do
their best at and be the top of the
ladder up mm-hmm
so it's kind of interesting um and I
like how Finn and Jake they start like
they're eating the ice cream Oh what the
businessmen do it let the businessmen do
it you know that's kind of fun um it
reminds me a Sorcerer's Apprentice that
I almost wanted to play that music yeah
but dude um so yeah no I like this one
and I think the more think about it
think I like them more than it's not the
business it's the job they just want the
job to you know be in charge of in rural
over and have complete control over
because like you say without that they
have no identity yeah so I think that's
kind of fun um didn't what do you got in
this one uh-huh
what one of the scenes I really liked is
where they're eating the ice cream and
Finn is playing the video game and while
the you know the businessmen are doing
all the actual adventuring and all that
that's all they're doing and then when
they get done he's like yeah we're
adventure masters we beat adventure
master so instead of actually going out
and do
like there used to they're just getting
so excited we're playing a simulation of
it they've gotten that lazy with
themselves that they can't even go out
and do the actual adventuring they're
just happy playing fake adventuring and
I like how it's kind of a slippery slope
to because the first Jake just doesn't
want to do this one thing but Finn does
he wants to come on that's the fun is
putting it together and then when they
see at first you know allowing this
convenience come in does make them work
a little better you know you say oh wow
there's swords a lot sharper though
those shoes are better you know I feel
more athletic this is good and even when
they take a break they get them water
and oranges and stuff that's like well I
feel hydrated and but they abuse it and
they like it too much so it's I like
that it's okay it's not that all evil
it's that it can become a slippery slope
yeah you know watching this episode I I
guess the show isn't over so you know
nobody knows but I have a theory that
maybe all of this I'm sure there's other
stuff that's gonna go on to prove me
wrong by always have it I have a theory
that maybe all of this is like one big
8-bit video game world that they live in
because he constantly has to save a
princess he has to fight you know these
blocks that shoot lasers everything's
bright and colorful they kind of look
like videogame characters and there's
different missions and different places
again I just see this very easily being
an 8-bit game if they have made an 8-bit
game how this they should like for the
computer because I think that'd be
awesome
they haven't made it yet they've made a
few other ones though a few games based
off of it I think they should do like an
8-bit game you know like the really
pixelated ones where you go and say you
know you go in the big block and some
Princess Bubblegum what are you doing
here I have a quest for you you know it
it feels like that you know it's like I
said especially with those cubes I'm
thinking like that this is like a game
is like an 8-bit game oh just wait
just wait okay okay but yeah and I said
I think what else with this one you got
anything else that really spawns to life
with it um let me think here for a
second
cuz you bring up the whole video game
thing kind of just threw me off this
nice thing about other episodes ah sorry
um let's see
I mean that's about it where's the snail
you have to re-watch it and I don't want
to rewatch and see just you know what I
know it's there it's gonna start
bothering you after all cuz you'll catch
it never like an episode here they'll be
like oh there is we should always have a
snail in the V logs yeah we should like
done that from the beginning well
they've been incredible ahead you hear
from the beginning so we have to come
over that just yeah just somewhere it's
just like even for afraid some people
just go there was so maybe you know what
though maybe he's already been in every
one of these and people should go back
and re-watch him no I think they can see
through that no but it was a good try I
tried but I'm somewhere in this episode
it to look really hard very as though it
just feel like one frame yes and those
who find it when the incredible prize of
looking at it so you should be very
proud
so yeah no I thought was a fun episode I
like I said I like the identity of the
job I like them becoming really lazy
over you know and I can get too much now
I like that giant Fidan machine they
create cuz I get they just it's like
they have a model that's like okay Finn
and Jake they're our model and they just
put everything around that you know just
something marketable yeah you know like
here's a giant machine but it looks like
Finn so it's the hero it's okay like
they they only have these vague ideas of
what it is and just how to sell it not
only what's good about it or what's
actually going to help so I like that I
thought worked out pretty good oh yeah
there well oddly saying they're really
well drawn out characters instead of
them just being like kind of like blank
slates in a sense like oh look they're
businessmen and they're doing it they
were just villains there's more to them
they're actually I don't see more human
but there's so much actually more behind
them than just oh look they're
businessmen yeah like I said there's
this need to I mean it's not just
because you know oh it's business and we
want to force that it's they feel this
is the only thing they know it's the
only way they can help yeah you know and
they just want to be helpful in like
it's just all they know so I like this
serval it's almost really sad commentary
and just guessing how they went in the
iceberg or whatever maybe that's made
that feeds even more into it so so no
fun episode that was those definitely
cool one so this is probably the last
time you'll see us in these clothes next
time we'll be naked
no we'll be in different clothes because
this last order tonight but yeah so
we'll just see you guys in the next one
take it oh hey critic
you